je voudrais installer sur intro à la
Réunion c'est un heureux mariage
[Musique]
nous vivons une vie de troupes c'est un
c'est un quotidien géré c'est une
expérience humaine avant d'être
artistique c'est un peu comme une course
de fond si vous voulez il ne faut pas
partir trop rapidement pour pouvoir
durer et bien fini
la vie imagine la vie c'est elle chanson
merci Emmanuel Jean Brun de nous
accueillir ici chez toi quel plaisir de
pouvoir évoquer le théâtre Volard plus
de 40 ans d'histoire qu'est-ce que ça
t'évoque quand on en parle
pas pour moi ça a été toute ma vie
puisque puisque David adulte a été a été
le théâtre sans que sans que j'ai voulu
puisque au départ j'étais j'étais
psychologue je suis restée psychologue
quelques années j'ai été le dernier
psychologue de la PéKa si ça dit des
choses aux gens il doute est venu l'idée
de te lancer de dans la création de
cette troupe c'est parce que bon au
départ on m'a demandé il y avait un
atelier théâtre au tampon et on m'a
demandé d'être un peu un regard
extérieur pour aider les gens et puis la
personne qui s'en occupait a disparu du
jour au lendemain et donc j'ai été
contraint de de prendre en main à faire
ensuite il y a eu deux années pendant
laquelle on a fait des pièces de théâtre
de répertoire
[Musique]
que vous ne vous sentez pas bien je vous
ferai bien boire une de mes potions et
puis au bout d'un moment je me suis dit
non quand même
à la Réunion faut faire du théâtre
réunionnais quoi il faut pas qu'on les
gens sont différents la langue est
différente et tout ça tout ça le climat
est différente je parle par rapport à la
métropole donc il faut que il faut
inventer quelque chose qui correspondent
au public
[Musique]
c'est pour ça que c'était important de
sortir ce livre aujourd'hui après tout
ce temps on regarde dans le rétroviseur
on se dit bon sang ça servi à quoi tout
ça est-ce qu'il y a pas une idée
générale qu'est-ce qui a pas un fil
conducteur on avait rien en profiter des
vacances pour jouer justement parce que
le théâtre officiel partait en congé
donc nous on avait le champ libre avec
le public donc en fait on travaillait
tout le temps et puis et puis on aimait
ça et comment s'est passé le travail de
collecte pour pouvoir mettre en forme ce
livre bon ça on a fait ça avec Emmanuel
Cambou donc qui était qui a été
longtemps dans dans la troupe moi je me
suis tapé tous les textes les légendes
et puis d'organiser un peu j'allais dire
le récit volardien quoi et lui de son
côté à
choisir les photos l'iconographie
l'important c'est que le thé Vollard a
écrit finalement l'histoire du théâtre à
la Réunion il y a toujours eu plus ou
moins une vingtaine de troubles de
cartes à la réunion de toute tendance
confondues par contre on se rend compte
que les gens pas oublier alors ça c'est
c'est sympa je vais je vais je vais
donner encore une formule que je
trouvais drôle c'est il y a quelqu'un
qui m'a dit moi j'ai jamais vu de pièce
du théâtre de pièces du thé de volaille
mais c'est bien
donc quand on est bien sans avoir vu
j'allais dire c'est formidable
c'est-à-dire qu'on est dans la mémoire
et est-ce qu'il y avait une création qui
devait absolument figurer dans dans le
livre bah c'est le pervenche c'est un
peu le pivot quoi parce que ça a été
formidable on sortait d'une grosse crise
puisqu'on avait été expulsé du grand
marché donc on a dû se refaire dans un
vieux cinéma à la position et et on
s'est plutôt que de diminuer les
activités on les a multiplié par 10
avec leurs 8 heures
ils sont contents
la Révolution le grand soir il s'en
foutent
immense Mika Midor pas de grossièreté et
qu'est-ce que devient la le théâtre va
là aujourd'hui il fallait qu'on se
renouvelle puisque
comment dire il faut qu'on se renouvelle
artistiquement j'allais dire de
nous-mêmes on a voulu évoluer évoluer
vers quelque chose qu'on connaissait pas
ou qu'il fallait qu'on découvre et qu'on
retravaille ça a été ça a été l'Opéra
qui est qui n'est jamais que du théâtre
chanté mais c'est quand même très
sophistiqué c'est très compliqué mais
dans notre métier c'est le must
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
est-ce qu'il y a un regret qui restera
gravé à jamais
j'ai envie de dire on s'est battu pour
le train par exemple
et on s'est battu pour que pour le
renouveau du train et ben il y a pas de
train la fierté ça a été de mener des
combats finalement quand on a commencé
il faut bien je vais dire une chose des
choses pas belles à dire mais il y avait
pas de noir sur scène
comprenez et donc et donc des choses ont
évolué des fois je me dis c'est
peut-être pour ça que voilà un survécu
c'est parce que
il y avait des gens qui aimaient bien et
qui voulaient soutenir ce qu'on était en
train de dire mais qui voulait pas
l'assumer est-ce que tu as encore un
rêve là je continue sur une carrière de
romancier donc qui est très belle très
intéressante donc ça me laisse la
possibilité de de faire des choses
nouvelles j'ai rien d'autre à demander
au bon Dieu
merci beaucoup Emmanuel Jean-Paul